so what else did we want to tell the
students James just how we'll be working
in this course we'll be using two main
tools a text editor code and a browser
to inspect our work all modern browsers
include a powerful set of tools commonly
referred to as developer tools which let
developers inspect the way a website
loads and runs dev tools also includes a
console that allows you to issue
JavaScript commands against your website
let's give it a try
cool what'd you have in mind let's open
up developer tools right now and run a
command let's say console log all right
this sounds like a good time for a quiz
let's find out what console dot log does
I want you to pull up the console and
type console dot log hello world what
happened when you ran the command type
it in here